the problem with black people and white
people is that people say black people
and white people
yeah and such as people I was watching
this video it's annoying video of this
lady calling the cops and this little 8
year old black girl who's selling water
they've seen it viral oh yeah yeah yeah
viral visions not supposed to sell water
she's calling the [ __ ] police she's
saying selling water without a permit
and her mom videotapes her and puts it
up and makes it viral and that's one of
those videos where it's everything's in
the right place
the white lady is overweight she's angry
looking like you want overweight white
lady the little black girl is as cute as
a button the mom is the mom is talking
to her in a way that's like not too
aggressive she was she out here calling
the police on a little girl trying to
sell water we see you boo like she's not
being horrible yeah and everything just
fell into place to this like perfect
example of like what's happening here
like is this racism or is this someone
who's just just complains about
everything would she be doing that for
an eight-year-old I don't know that's
why I hear the argument a lot of like
you wouldn't do this if it was a man you
wouldn't this was a woman you wouldn't
know this is black but it's like you're
not basically a set of it's just like
one example force one example but you
not proof you know there's no proof I
was in a Hills Chamber of Commerce and
whenever somebody wanted a new seating
like like sidewalk seating they had just
get through but all it would take is one
housewife from the area to get a stick
up their ass about the rules and say now
no and like it'll be done by 8 p.m.
there won't be any hurt on the on the
people around us women clean up and if
she goes no then it's like 24 more hoops
to jump you know and it's just because
these housewives have nothing to do
better than to enforce rules so it could
be that could be [ __ ] these black kids I
don't I don't I don't have any idea she
was on um it's on an interview talking
about it which is a terrible idea by the
way who the white lady yeah and she put
all this makeup on everything which is
also a terrible I think me me from the
Drew Carey Show just not
I forgot about her um but the whole
thing was she was saying that she was
working and that she had the window open
the little girl was shouting and
screaming she's trying to make it look
bad as possible yes she was a victim and
she said she apologized to both the
little girl and the mom but they won't
accept her apology which is like okay
well you knows nothing wrong with
accepting someone's apology clearly she
shouldn't have done that
like I shouldn't tell a little
eight-year-old not sell water on a hot
day who gives a [ __ ] like that doesn't
make just going hey come on guys screen
by my window yeah yeah like maybe she
was saying that there's a hot day and so
she had her window rolled down the kid
was screaming but apparently she didn't
talk to them she didn't talk to the kid
and she didn't talk to the mom she just
called the police well see that's a
problem you're so antisocial they'll
just go straight to like someone deal
with it instead of just like hey I'm
it's like when you get a note in your
apartment door saying something it's
like just or the front door like just
come to my apartment knock you asked
once just try it
humanity once and then go to the other
step so they compared her with this
white chick called on Chicago police on
the BBQ there and they're the same
person
[ __ ] not really but yeah they look so
similar man like in the way the shape of
their body not housewife yep it's an
alleged white housewife it's a [ __ ]
shitty the worst position to be in in
the world there's definitely nothing to
do look come on come on look at the two
of them together they're both in the
phone with these like sexually ambiguous
forms like you know that that's a woman
but you know both of them they're
overweight and it's just weird it's
weird they're like unclear you that I'm
gonna go out on a limb I don't think
most I will say most people that are
shaped like that don't feel good I don't
feel good they don't feel good right
they're upset it's tough you ever ever
have somebody screaming about something
like you know what is here but doesn't
meet them with like what happened to you
yeah are you so angry okay so why you so
mad selling water without a permit hmm I
got a discussion with somebody at
Twitter way back about that guy Michael
Brown got I can't breathe what's that
Michael Brown
Eric garner was Erik Roner yeah
and he somebody's like yet what you
understand is I had a business and like
I sell let's say I sell cigarettes if
somebody's undercutting me with no
permits right outside that really hurts
my business I was like okay sure I'll
give you that do you think the
punishment for that should be choking
someone maybe til I can't breathe
and he's like oh no no that's too much
of a punishment okay well here's the
problem with that the official version
of that is that he didn't have any
cigarettes on him they did not know he
had nothing he had nothing what
yeah I know he had nothing when they
they had arrested him before for that
but he was clean so all that cigarette
he was telling him leave him the [ __ ]
alone
he's like you're all I was out here
[ __ ] with me just leave me the [ __ ]
alone
they started I wanted to frisk them and
there was for no reason oh my god 96
Edwards is still too much it's like just
give me the ticket [ __ ] yes
they shouldn't touch him I mean and he
wasn't a violent guy wasn't like like
threatening them and some sort of a way
and and then they tried to say that it
wasn't a chokehold my [ __ ] let me put
you in that dude I by these two cops
that I wanted to they were one was sent
right after that in New York that's not
a chokehold and I want I wanted to stop
ago actually I'm friends with an expert
on the subject and he does say jokey to
death like that yeah I will choke you to
death with that house underneath listen
he's got his hands grip that is like the
same ver it's a backwards version of
what you would call like a marcelo
garcia guillotine which means like
there's certain guys that are really
good at getting the blade of the forearm
across your esophagus it's very painful
and like some of like a maul easton
taught me how to do this in shoutout to
Boulder Colorado I'm all Eastern is a
jiu-jitsu coach and he's got a fantastic
guillotine and one of the things about
his guillotine is he knows how to get
that blade of that bone right into your
esophagus it's horrific it feels
terrible and they do it like with a high
elbow so you can't escape it it's and it
it's an immediate feeling that guy has
his forearm right across that guy's
throat yeah there's no doubt about it if
I'm holding that like that and I'm
clammed he has his hands clasp together
can you make it a little bigger so you
can see this is a right hand resist like
yeah see but you could still choke
someone out even if his hand I can't
tell if his hands are connected I think
they are it looks like he's got a man
inside his Eric garner smelling so the
hundred percent hundred percent and then
arms behind his back too but the point
is the guy who's choking him the way
he's doing that you could choke a guy
like that with one arm you don't even
have to have that right arm and play if
he's got that left arm with anything
like that always do is hook the the back
of the head or put the shoulder rather
the traps you if your arms from San Jose
he cut somebody no shields yeah yeah
that's made one-armed guillotine yeah
Jake do anybody like that Tito Ortiz did
that in the UFC before he choked
somebody out with a one-armed
guillotined Luke Rockhold did it to
Michael Bisping he got him in a mounted
one-armed guillotine I mean here's the
problem why don't the other cops ever go
hey Tony that's enough
yeah you dissin man that's a goddamn
chokehold I know choke holds i
commentate them on for a [ __ ] living
that's chokehold and if you don't think
it's a chokehold let me put you in it
let me put you in it to see how long you
last
well it's it's [ __ ] chokehold